- [Pastor] Don't let
anybody make you believe
that if you fall right
now, you can't get up.
Don't let nobody make you
believe that you too old.
Don't let nobody make you believe
that where you are is too hard for God.
You took your eyes off him.
Don't think that God, if you
call on him, he won't help you.
See because the bible said...
- [Mark] Hi Amanda.
- Hi.
- [Interviewer] Hi.
- I lost my voice.
- [Mark] So how are you doing?
- I'm doing good. I lost my voice, I mean,
they don't want me to say much.
- [Mark] How'd you lose your voice?
- Basically, you know what I'm sayin'?
I go so hard.
I tell the truth so much.
The truth is out there.
You know what I mean?
You know what I'm saying?
You're showing where we
are in this country and,
you know what I'm sayin'?
thank you so much.
I don't think it should be forever and
I do need to
relax and
enjoy life
about my nervous condition.
I don't think I'm cool.
China,
America put in a lot of
work for me to be humble
and be the person I am today.
So, I shouldn't indulge that.
- [Mark] Amanda do you recall at one point
you were a college student and
you had your life together?
You probably weren't using drugs.
- I was at CSUN.
They took my voice.
I ain't trippin', you
know what I'm sayin'?
People just do things.
Especially, you know what I'm sayin'?
- [Mark] Do you remember the old Amand...
- People with money.
People with money.
You know what I'm sayin'?
- [Mark] Do you remember?
- People do things
because they're jealous.
You know what I'm sayin'?
- [Mark] Do you remember your life...
It's an unorthodox word.
- Amanda.
- You know what I'm sayin'?
There's not a word that
hasn't been made up yet.
- [Mark] Amanda so do you...
- So, I'm not gonna say
people were jealous.
That's why they took my voice.
I ain't trippin'.
You know what I'm sayin' here?
- [Mark] Amanda do you remember your life
before you got involved with drugs
and living on the street and all that?
- Yeah, I mean I was living
with my boyfriend that.
Fuck him. He's a pedophile.
You know what I'm sayin'?
But it doesn't matter.
I just wanted (mumbles)
The poor me and help me right now.
I might be in forever pain.
Two or three minutes.
I work so hard.
It's like there's nothing else to say.
I had my last date.
They were sayin' somethin' to him
for him to not fuck with me.
But, I'm just like fuck him.
And I still got the money.
So it was a blessing.
I just wanna say sorry everybody.
I have to do what I had
to do to stay alive.
You know what I'm sayin'?
So downtown shit, it's not my city.
But I'm hurt that you guys are gonna,
in your own world and
you don't wanna invite me
or hang out with me.
I understand.
That's it.
Bye.
- [Mark] Amanda, do you have
kids or anything like that?
- No, I don't have kids.
- [Mark] Do you ever contact
with any members of your family?
- Yeah, I have contact with my dad.
- [Mark] With your dad?
- But he's (mumbles)
and he's fuckin' with me.
- [Mark] How much rock,
crack cocaine are you using?
- I mean, it's more like
it makes me feel like...
You know what I'm sayin'?
The itch for it is like I'm thirsty.
It's not like I wanna feel high.
The is like, the itch is like,
the craving for it is like I'm thirsty.
My mouth is dry.
- [Mark] Can you do without it?
But you actually need...
- Yeah I can do without crack,
- [Mark] You can?
- but my life is gonna have to change.
- [Mark] Are you open to maybe changing?
- I don't notice I'm running,
but I do what I do.
It's up to them to remind me.
You know what I'm sayin'?
I'm puttin' on, but at the
same time more trickery.
I'm puttin' on more trickery
has got in this shit now.
You know, I'm horny.
I'm horny.
So, I'm the asshole.
When you see me,
let's go up.
Turn out.
Everybody gets murdered,
and some people die of age.
It don't matter.
- [Mark] Do you have
no brothers or sisters?
- Yeah, they're good.
- [Mark] I talked to your cousin.
- Everybody's taken care of.
- [Mark] Your cousin saw your video.
- Arianna, you're beautiful.
You know what I'm sayin'?
Everybody's taken care of except me.
(clapping)
So, I'm good.
(mumbles)
So I can look like a different person.
But I ain't trippin'.
Its' good, let's go.
(bus noise)
- However you use the government.
The money situation.
- [Mark] Amanda.
Do you see that you're kind of
getting worse and worse
every time we speak?
- I mean, I'm not getting worse and worse.
That's just the lane you wanna go.
That's just the lane you wanna go,
so I'm just gonna stop that right now
and say I got better.
But, my livin' situation,
my money situation,
I don't have friends,
it's a big situation.
So ain't nobody fuckin' wit' it.
People didn't die.
People did not die.
People did not die for this to happen,
but it hit's before they die.
So, whatever fuck 'em.
Life goes on.
- [Mark] Would you like to get clean?
Would you like to go into rehab?
Would you like to...
- Yeah I'm very clean.
I'm good, I'm ready for the world.
But it's things.
Such a cliche situation
that's holding me back.
Not a normal situation,
but it's like drugs.
You know what I'm sayin'?
Serious, I have like no friends, no money.
Whatever.
- [Mark] What does your father say to you?
- He doesn't say anything, he...
He cool though, he's a good guy.
I just wanna have more people in my life
that are from my situation.
(mumbles)
- Your own world, come fuck with me.
I'm (mumbles) here forever babe,
or something for two to three minutes,
30 minutes, whatever.
But I'm just try..
- [Mark] Amanda, what would
you like to see in your life?
Is there anything you'd
like to see happen?
- Nothin', I just wanna see.
You know what I'm sayin'?
- [Mark] Is there anything
you hope to see happen?
- The club,
amusement park.
You know what I'm sayin'?
Maybe not be such a punk,
but fuck all you niggas.
I'm the realest nigga alive.
Straight up.
That's it.
I mean I love you all.
I don't know what's
goin' on in the country,
but it seems like, I dunno, (mumbles)
So.
I hope everything's together.
That's just in my heart,
if everything's together.
So,
I need that.
I need somebody to come
tell me everything's good,
except the government.
Everything.
That's it.
(car honks)
- [Preacher] See told, the bible says,
I mean,
we know,
we know exactly what
people began to think.
See, when we
when we got a few days clean,
God takes us and miraculously
place, takes us off the
sidewalk, off the curb,
and put us in a place.
All of the sudden we start
thinkin' we done did somethin'.
Yeah, we go to thinkin',
you know, I can go back and
hang out and you know I...